hi there steve kaufman uh today first of
all i apologize i'm not going to do this
video in portuguese although i had said
that i would and that leads me to the
subject of my discussion which is how to
maintain your languages
many people even if they've only learned
one foreign language
they may only visit the country where
the language is spoken once a year once
every few years
so the problem they have is how to how
to maintain those language skills or
even improve them when they're away from
the environment where the language can
be used
in my case i claim to have 13 languages
so it becomes even more difficult to
maintain these languages so this becomes
a real issue now when i say i'm going to
do a video in portuguese
i did have the intention of doing a
video on portuguese this past week i've
been doing a number of portuguese
lessons
at link such as cafe brazil
and so forth doing a lot of listening
and last night it just so happens that i
was with some portuguese people here in
vancouver had a dinner
and in trying to speak portuguese i
realized that my portuguese is just not
quite up to the task
now
to be honest uh you know i still get
compliments people are very encouraging
they say you're doing fine
uh
much like happened when i visited uh
berlin or some while ago i was very much
aware of the deficiencies of my german
and their people said oh no no you're
doing fine so i do think to some extent
we tend to be more aware of our own
shortcomings
whereas other people especially native
speakers listening to us are more
inclined to give us credit for what we
can do they're less aware of the fact
that we're frustrated because we can't
do as well as we would like to do
however the issue then is how do you
maintain your languages now in my own
case
with uh french and japanese
i can turn them on whenever i want and i
really don't miss a beat
and that's because i lived in france for
three years i lived in japan for nine
years so there's absolutely no question
that the more you have spoken a language
the better you can speak it i mean i say
this again and again even though i am
a proponent of input-based learning to
build up your potential build up your
vocabulary build up your comprehension
and build up your potential to speak
well in order to speak well
you ultimately have to speak a lot and
so i obviously have spoken french a lot
i've spoken japanese a lot
my next language which i can probably
turn on although i
i'm aware of slipping
in the language is mandarin chinese but
i have spoken a lot of mandarin chinese
over the years and
when for example in vancouver i was
invited to participate on television
programs in mandarin i would typically
spend a few hours that day listening to
mandarin cds
to kind of refresh my memory something
that i wouldn't have to do in french or
japanese that's not to say that i
couldn't improve in french and japanese
i would love to when i have listened to
audiobooks in french or in japanese it
definitely elevates my language skills
so listening to interesting material is
always a way of refreshing yourself
in languages and especially languages
that you already speak well the same
would be true of mandarin but in
mandarin i would say that my vocabulary
is not as broad as it is in french or
japanese
spanish i can still probably turn on
but again it wouldn't be quite as easy
uh
swedish german kind of more or less with
gaps and more problems but once i reach
further down
into italian portuguese not to mention
the languages that i've learned more
recently
then it's just not that easy to get
myself up to a level where i can have a
conversation comfortably
in russian for example when i
participated in
that language conference in moscow i
spent a good
three weeks
going over my lessons
at link
working with material from echo muskvie
going through there looking up you know
words and and and this is the where i'm
coming to i had lots of online
discussions with our tutors at link with
evgeny and with elena in particular two
of our excellent russian tutors at link
and so therefore when i came to make my
presentation i had kind of revved myself
up
uh
you know in the case of romanian i was
starting from scratch so there
uh but i had the advantage of having all
of this vocabulary from other romance
languages
so now i go to brazil to portuguese
and um i mean the vocabulary basically i
know 90 of the vocabulary because it's
so similar to spanish if not 90 i know a
high percentage of the vocabulary
and so i thought i'd just listen a bit
and then i should be able to speak
well i went to this dinner and i had a
lot of trouble i had a lot of trouble
with some basic
you know
verb endings and
searching for words and just stumbling
to say stuff that that i know i
should be able to say because i can
understand it very clearly when i listen
to it so i decided that i would delay
making my portuguese video and i've now
lined up a lot of discussions with our
tutors at link so i'm going to try to
get in
maybe four or five hours
of online you know skype
discussions in portuguese and at the end
of each of these uh i will get my report
with all the phrases and words that i
didn't use correctly and i will myself
become aware of where my gaps are so i
can kind of look at them because
there's with all the input learning that
i do and and also you know i
when i get back to portuguese i'll
review the verb endings and stuff like
that when you go to speak you can't
really use it
to get good at speaking you have to
speak you have to speak now if you don't
have the vocabulary if you haven't
exposed yourself to a lot of the
language
uh then just speaking isn't going to get
there because you won't understand what
people are saying you have no words to
use but given the fact that i have this
fear call it a potential base in
portuguese
before i
you know make my video in portuguese i
want to spend some time talking in
portuguese
the other thing i've decided to do
whereas in the past a lot of my
listening
has been in european portuguese because
i had not found
good podcasts from brazil whereas i had
found those excellent podcasts from rtf
and in terms of building up your
vocabulary and getting used to the
language i believe it doesn't matter
what accent you listen to
however i now have to make a decision
if i make my presentation you know my
natural inclination is to speak with a
spanish accent because that's the sort
of closest language that i speak the
best
uh and and i i have found myself even
you know
psychologically resisting
moving towards the more
portuguese pronunciation and hanging
back in that spanish pronunciation
because it's more comfortable i feel
more
sure of myself speaking that way i don't
feel quite comfortable imitating that
portuguese accent because i think i'll
sound silly and this is one of the
things that i talk about a lot that a
lot of the reasons we have trouble as
adults pronouncing like native speakers
are getting closer to their
pronunciation is that we're afraid to
sound silly imitating their way of
speaking so we hang back in something
that's more comfortable to us which
might be our native language or in my
case going from spanish to portuguese
the spanish is more feels more secure
than the portuguese but then the second
issue becomes which form of portuguese
and most of my listening has been in
european portuguese but because i am
planning to go to brazil
uh sometime next year
i just and because the friends i have
here locally are brazilians i decided
that i should move away from that even
though most of my listening has been in
european portuguese so
again this wonderful world that we live
in
uh you know um i just went on the web i
said i've got to find some good podcasts
there must be some good podcasts so
globo is the big newspaper i think in
rio or sao paulo so i just went global
podcasts and i found a bunch of podcasts
in fact i found another site as well so
i've now found two
brazilian podcast sites with
programs on health on how to use the
language
on news and i've only started looking so
i'm going to be listening to a lot of
those podcasts
together with cafe brazil
over the next little while and i'm gonna
spend one week dedicated to
uh brazilian portuguese and i've made my
my decision i'm going to in terms of the
the way i would like to pronounce the
language i'm gonna have to take that
leap
and instead of saying you know
uh
it's not important it's important
as they say in portuguese and i feel a
bit silly at first because in spanish
importantes in spanish everything is
kind of clear whereas in portugal in
brazilian is important
so i got to get used to doing that and
initially i'm going to sound silly doing
that
to myself but that's the commitment that
i've made
so
uh you know and oh i was going to say so
the world we live in like if i were a
language learner in germany
uh 200 years ago
who wanted to learn portuguese it would
be difficult where do i find a
portuguese speaker where do i find
material whereas today i just go to the
internet i can find uh podcasts i can
find grammar resources i can find people
to talk to and so i i can just do
whatever i want
and so
getting back to the sort of the theme
here is how do we warm up a language
well all right
it depends on how firm a grasp you have
on the language like if i have to do a
video now in czech or in russian i'm
going to spend at least two weeks with
heavy listening devoted to those
languages and with a good you know five
hours or so of online discussions with
native speakers to get myself up to a
level and i'll focus on one at a time so
the big thing i think to refresh
yourself is
uh the
more you have spoken in the language
in the past the less you need to
practice speaking but if you haven't
spoken a lot in the language and there's
really only
i guess french and japanese where i have
lived in the environment for any length
of time and so where i haven't spoken
these languages a lot to get myself up
to a level where i can speak comfortably
and do a video i have to speak a lot
but the speaking is in itself not enough
because speaking is a good practice in
speaking but it also points out your
gaps and then you can go back and in
your listening and reading you can then
deliberately try to notice
those areas where you have a weakness
and try to get your brain to notice them
so that when you next go to speak you
try to do better in the might be in the
conditional or in the future a third
person plural future whatever it might
be you start to identify where those
problems are and then you need to
practice them in speaking so
it's not realistic to expect that people
who speak even one other language or
more can just turn that language on just
like that
especially if they hadn't had the
opportunity of living in the country
where the language is spoken
and so if you are going to be in a
situation where you want to do well in
the language
using the resources that are available
on the internet within a couple of weeks
you can bring your level up at least to
where it was before and i think beyond
where it was before even if it
subsequently falls off
you've taken it up another level and
every time you have one of these spurts
of concentration you're taking the
language up yet another level so that is
how i think uh that is certainly how i
am going about warming up my language
for my portuguese video
and i promise i won't uh i won't
cop out again
uh next week at this time i will do my
video in portuguese but i will be
putting a lot of effort into
not only my input activities but a good
five hours i hope of online discussion
with native speakers from brazil thank
you for listening bye for now